if you had to have a person that you
could kidnap and have as your personal
entertainer in your home 24/7 like in
this film who would you choose
Nicki Minaj can you sing any Nicki no
okay that's the point to entertain us at
any time
all right but I have to go for Bowie I
think Bowie Bowie
I agree out have Bowie as well I
answered the remaining Beatles you know
Paula ring but I wouldn't want to
subject them to that know if the person
could be kept to their satisfaction in
great deal of luxury I think I'd
probably have Jeff Bridges we have the
same one Prince so one character I won't
say who progresses to their younger self
in this bonus I don't want to spoil
anything
yeah if we were to have either of you
regress to your younger selves what
would we see I was more mature when I
was younger don't I was in terrible punk
bands somebody reading you see bad hair
bad makeup and shoulder pads it's quite
fats and those also quite I was also
very very self-conscious I remember if I
could say something to my own self it
would be no one's looking at you no
one's thinking about what you're doing
everywhere too consumed with worrying
about basically well it starts like bury
inside okay it's like a little it's like
just like and then it's like yeah then
it comes up and then it is like
so what is the number one reason
somebody should go see this film Halle
Berry because it's fun it's escapism it
really is a ray of sunshine
[Music]
you